get your pills ready and settle in your
microwave chairs everyone because we
have maniac ending explained now for
those of you who haven't checked out my
individual episode breakdowns I'll put a
link in the description below I only did
the first few episodes because I
underestimated what a beast of a show
this would be to break down individually
so I'm summing it all up here in this
video so without further ado here's
maniac ending explained and questions
answered if you made it this far and
don't want spoilers for the entire
series turn back now and remember you
signed an NDA I truly love this show
it was quirky well-made acted and chock
full of little mysteries and homage is
nods to the Coen brothers Kubrick the
matrix and of course director Cary
Fukunaga zone true detective gotta give
props to Twitter user Ben Travers for
spotting the big hug mug that made its
way into the show but it was the message
the thing this show is really trying to
say that really brought the whole story
together so let's interpret the ending
and answer some of the questions you
might still be wondering in episode 10
Owen and Annie patients number 1 and 9
have made it through ULP testing pills a
B and C a rogue supercomputer meltdown
and their own worst fears and traumas
relatively unscathed
annie has come to terms with her sister
Ellie's death and has finally been able
to let go of her guilt Owen has faced
the reality of well his reality what's
real versus what he's just seeing in his
mind but more importantly Owen begins
identifying his issues and addressing
them for example his outbursts the ones
that affect the people he loves like
with Olivia seen many times in Owens ULP
reflections here in the self-help book
here at the full-moon seance and here as
the waitress in Owens mob reflection
more self-aware Owen breaks ties with
Annie after the ULP sends an apology
letter to Olivia and builds up the
courage to testify truthfully against
his brother Jed the Milgram's then sent
him to a psychiatric institution Annie
now at peace with her sister's death
visits Hank to reconnect only to
discover dad's actually come out of the
a void no longer burdened by guilt she
freely explains her story and what
happened at never Dean pharmaceutical
and biotech to Papa Hank also played by
Hank Azaria here Annie's dad touches on
the whole point of the series
listen closely Owen listened to all of
my stories but in their reflections I
kept giving him all these reasons not to
trust me
but he just kept trying to help me he
acted like a friend in therapy own
explains why he's disconnected from
Annie
he claims that if he didn't one of two
things would happen option a he
eventually finds out she never existed
option B she's real which is worse
eventually Owen always does something
wrong and outbursts like with Olivia or
something drastic like jumping from a
building and when that happens Annie
will look at him differently run away
and change her number it's easier if
she's not real but the title of this
episode is option C Annie sees Owen in a
newspaper headline and visits him she
listens to his story she acts like a
friend and for the first time Owen is
freed from his trauma just as he did for
Annie the two escaped and race off to
Salt Lake City the end so what does this
ending mean I've seen post debating
whether or not Annie and Owen are still
in a simulation and this was not reality
but I don't believe that to be true
here's my take Annie and Owen are real
whatever world this is regardless if
there are alternate realities this is
real these two people start with deep
unresolved emotional trauma for Annie it
was the death of her sister for Owen it
was his outburst with Olivia and his
relationship with his family and nothing
could resolve these traumas not even a
robotic super computer that delved into
the inner workings of their minds it was
only through connecting with each other
Owen and Annie 1 and 9 that they finally
came to accept their reality accept
themselves and move forward this is the
premise of maniac the healing power of
connection our traumas our defense
mechanisms our blind spots the only true
way to disarm them to see again is
through connection this mysterious
intangible thing we feel only through
others it wasn't miracle science or pop
therapy that ultimately helped these two
it was their connection to each other as
the credits roll we get one more look at
Annie and Owen racing off into the
sunset and as they do they pass by dr.
mantle array and as Umi heading
into their own happy ending dr. mantel
ray muses over a theory he's just
developed the same theory here at the
beginning of the series let's listen to
it because it's very important maybe it
was chance maybe it was inevitable this
one changed amoeba becomes the ancestor
of every living plant on earth which in
turn floods the planet with oxygen
[Music]
paving the way for every other form of
life we know leading to more Souls more
connections in there for more new worlds
branching outward from the first these
forces of nature when they converge be
they astronomical collisions biological
unions demonstrates the infinite
potential of our connections
this truth also extends to the human
heart maniac leads with this message and
ends with it to the infinite potential
of our connections the world painted in
maniac is one of tremendous loneliness a
world where you can pay people to act
like friends where you can hide away in
an a void and pay for products by
listening to others spew ads this is a
world barren of connection and the
people who inhabited are weighed down by
its absence but by the end any you know
and mantle Raya Nezumi are transformed
by their connections now there are some
theories suggesting Annie and Owen are
still in the simulation that they are in
fact McMurphy a term the show uses to
describe ULP testers who've been
collected by Gertie to permanently live
in these reflections with her in the
real world they are essentially
brain-dead remember these twins they pop
up many times throughout the show here
is a Gerdes entourage in the sounds here
alongside lady Norah in the elf fantasy
again with Queen Gertie and also at
snore EES party for Ernie the alien
Easter egg Ernie the alien is the name
of Jed's gerbil remember early on in the
series own describe saving a wounded
hawk that went on to eat Jed's gerbil
Snorri like owen accidentally kills
Ernie the evidence for this McMurphy
theory is as follows first check out the
references to the events from the ULP
reflections here in the sign up sheet at
the psychiatric facility notice when
deal amuri ax aka Wendy the lemur three
names above it is Urich remember Urich
AKA greg fu n Aslan from the elf
reflection second dr. mantle raised in
Izumi's cars these are the same cars
from Owen and Annie's reflections and
look at mantle Ray's license plate oh
one nine nine one a oh four Owen the
numbers one and nine which were owned in
Annie's numbers and then a four Annie
finally the poop bot Owens dead hawk and
Groucho the lost dog following Annie and
Owen on their drive to Salt Lake City
how could these things appear in reality
things so connected to their previous
reflections could it be they are
actually still in a simulation no well
there is no definitive answer and the
beauty of this show is that it's open to
interpretation similar to the leave it
up to the audience ending of Inception
but I believe these are merely our
stick strokes from the show's creator
the hawk bought and dog being symbolic
of Owen and Annie's transformation
through the story the cars I believe are
a zoom he's doing in episode nine we
learned a zoom the program Guardi after
greta mantle raised mind who's to say
during all the additions and
reprogramming bits of Izumi's life
didn't go in as well and if this is all
a simulation how did dr. mantle Raina
zoom he passed by Owen and Annie on the
road as I see it this interpretation
deflates the premise of the show the
power of human connection the power of
friendship all seems pretty irrelevant
and horribly morose if the ideas they've
been McMurphy but be it real life or not
it shouldn't matter we can take whatever
interpretation we wish it doesn't change
the fact that Owen and Annie's major
transformation was all due to the
connection they made with each other
this is the ending of maniac now I'd
like to address some of the questions
I've seen online and that people still
have starting with who was Grimson aka
secret-agent Jed was he just in Owens
mind yes but more as an imaginary friend
he was the brother Owen always wanted it
was impossible for Owen to connect with
his family so he invented a brother he
could actually relate with you could say
he was a part of Owens mind trying to
help him get past his defense mechanisms
his blind spots and confront his trauma
thus his importance in episode 9 and the
Rubik's Cube who is McMurphy
McMurphy in terms of the narrative could
possibly be Gerdes original victim but
most likely it's a reference to One Flew
Over the Cuckoo's Nest
why does Owen hate balderdash so much
according to director Cary Fukunaga it's
because the game is all lies similar to
his family being full of lies and then
pushing Owen to lie on the stand for Jed
what's with the dated technology in the
alternate New York what years it this
one was answered by creator Patrick
Somerville to me it's not our timeline
Somerville says it's our zeitgeist of
2018 and it's a different history of
Technology it's a different kind of
version of our reality so 2018 zeitgeist
but a world where the microchip was
never invented maybe something like that
Somerville explains he and Fukunaga were
looking for the analog version of trends
that would be familiar to today's
audiences take the ad buddies for
example which are essentially the
physical manifestations of in
two grams sponsored content or web ads
this was all an attempt to throw viewers
off their axis why all the references to
mirrors the moon and rainbows first the
mirrors the mysterious last chapter of
Don Quixote a is hidden behind a mirror
in Episode five elf
Annie peers into a mirror and becomes
lucid these dreamlike scenarios they
enter are called reflections simply put
one of the themes of this show is
self-acceptance
that's why mirrors and looking into
oneself play a big role the moon has
also seen many times owen gazes up at it
after leaving Olivia
he wears a warren moon football jersey
in the Lemur kidnapping reflection also
the invisible moon on their journey to
the lake of the clouds in astrology the
Sun dictates your zodiac personality all
your moon sign represents your emotions
and your inner mood side note the knight
of the white moon and the knight of
reflections are characters in Don
Quixote a the rainbows are also symbolic
representing promise or peace so that's
it for my take on the ending of maniac I
thoroughly enjoyed this mini-series and
I hope you did too
I'd love to hear if you have any
unanswered questions in the comment
section and of course if you enjoyed the
video don't forget to Like and subscribe